[Musique]
ou alors ne devrait pas être mal là là
je suis presque comme un spectateur
devant mon travail et du coup ça fait
forcément une impression un peu où je
peux me dire bon ben j'ai bien travaillé
j'arrive un peu à ce que j'ai toujours
voulu skalli a essayé de faire partie de
la famille des pintes que j'ai amené
depuis que subtilement musée les
rembrandt tout le monde
enfin ce qui nous émerveille de compin
un peu ce qu'on voit en essayant de
retranscrire la beauté qui nous a
marqués on a peur en vieillissant c'est
de perdre cette faculté d'une de
s'émerveiller parce que s'il a pu cette
faculté là du coup main y'a plus rien
qu'on a pu envie de peindre
lui l'idée de faire toute une série de
portraits de gens qui vivaient dans la
rue et que j'ai voulu faire poser comme
des gens vraiment qu'ils étaient
contents d'être d'être vu dans une
attitude pas du tout dégradantes ni ni
misérabiliste
ça les a un peu transformés parce que
tout d'un coup que quelqu'un les regarde
ça nous rappelait par armand fabrice par
exemple bon il était dans une phase
dépressive et il m'a dit après que ça
l'avait complètement ressuscité de poser
dans le tout d'un coup et c'est ce qui
s'est passé quelque chose de très très
puissant très fort
la personne qui posent à elle a le temps
de on va capter plein de choses des
landes en tous temps alors que la photo
c'est vraiment le truc king bon danger
peindre les portraits de son domicile et
ben si j'avais pas lu tout ce temps avec
eux serait pas du tout donner la même
émotion
dont on est marquée par des drames qui
se jouent aussi bien chez dédé est fou
où tout cette histoire de deux migrants
c'est tellement terrifiante forcément on
en est imprégnée
[Musique]
autoportrait de jeunesse souvent les
gens peuvent penser que c'est du
narcissisme mais c'est pas du tout ça en
fait c'est juste au contraire une forme
d'humilité et toi tu de pimbo voilà tu
peins comme tu es c'est pas du tout une
voyez comme je suis bon
enfin ça m'empêche que